wenn ihr nach deutschland kommt dann
werdet ihr hier viele bäckereien sehen
bäckereien sind sehr populär und viele
deutsche kaufen da ihr frühstück
mittagessen und auch nochmal ihr
nachmittags kuchen ein
und weil ihr diese orte bestimmt oft
besucht zeigen wir euch heute wie man in
einer deutschen bäckerei etwas bestellt
los geht's
[Musik]
zwei normale brötchen bitte ich hätte
gern einmal bitte zwei normale brötchen
ja zwei normale brötchen hätte ich gern
ich hätte gerne zwei normale brötchen
und drei mehr korn brötchen dazu nehme
ich auch noch drei mehr kongolesen bitte
und dann kommen noch drei mehr können
brötchen dazu zwei mehr kommen brötchen
und drei kürbis kein brötchen zwei
croissants bitte und jetzt zwei crosser
und noch dazu zwei croissants bitter ich
hätte gerne zwei croissants eine brezel
bitte guten tag ich hätte gerne eine
brezel bitte noch eine brezel wird kann
ich bitte eine brezel haben ein baguette
bitte ich hätte gern ein baguette bitte
ein wenig beeilen
belegte brötchen mit käse ein belegtes
brötchen mit schinken bitte
denn sie haben hätte ich gerne ein
belegtes brötchen mit schinken ein
belegtes brötchen mit mett und zwiebeln
ich hätte gerne ein brot ich hätte gern
ein brot hallo ich hätte gern ein brot
bitte ich hätte gern ein brot butter ein
halbes roggenbrot geschnitten bitte ich
hätte gerne ein halbes trocken brot
geschnitten
können sie mir ein halbes roggenbrot
geschnitten geben bitte was haben sie
denn für kuchen
ich hätte gern ein stück erdbeerkuchen
ich hätte gern einen erdbeerkuchen
zwei stück kuchen bitte zwei stücke
käsekuchen bitte zwei stücke käsekuchen
für mich und mein freund
hallo ich hätte gerne zwei stück
käsekuchen
ich hätte gern ein pudding teilchen ich
hätte gerne eins von diesen pudding
teilchen bitte
[Musik]
jetzt bestellen wir mal tatsächlich
etwas in einer bäckerei ja nicht was
hättest du gerne ich hätte gerne zwei
mehr kommen
wir hätten gerne ein stück käsekuchen
bitte
außerdem hätten wir gerne noch einen
großen dazu bitte ich hätte gerne einem
und schnecke bitte zum mitnehmen
[Musik]
ich guck mal franziskus kuchen
dankeschön francisco hat sich einen
käsekuchen bestellt hanisch
lieblingskuchen ist eine mond schnecke
jetzt ist es zeit für euch um weiter
deutsch zu lernen und zwar könnt ihr
unsere app sieht lang ausprobieren dort
haben wir interaktive video flash cards
und damit könnt ihr mit kleinen
geschichten schritt für schritt die
deutsche grammatik und das wichtigste
deutsche vokabular liane janz ist auch
dabei und er spielt in den geschichten
immer die witzige rolle
ein bisschen spaß muss sein da geschehen
ist so sehen und wissen im nächsten
woche zschopau